how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder this
is going to be
my falcon and the winter soldier episode
4 breakdown and this episode was
extremely important for what is about to
happen in the final two episodes of the
series so i'm breaking this down
top 7 style there are seven really
important things that you need to know
about this episode
going into the final two episodes of the
falcon and the winter soldier and i'll
tell you
everything that you need to know but
quick reminder about my falcon and the
winter soldier captain america
shield giveaway to enter for a chance to
win just subscribe to me and my other
channel cosmic culture i'll put the link
in the description down below
now if you have not seen the falcon and
the winter soldier episode 4 this
is your spoiler warning and trust me
there are some pretty big spoilers so
here's your final chance to click away
starting with the opening scene and
number one of the important facts
is bucky is now free after the events of
captain america
civil war bucky goes to wakanda and king
t'challa aka the black panther promises
steve rogers that him and his team
will do anything and everything they can
to help
get rid of the brainwashing that hydra
did to bucky essentially promising that
they're going to try and get rid of the
winter soldier programming inside of him
and we never really got to see any of
this happen yes we did see bucky in
wakanda
sort of after the fact we heard some
wakandans and king t'challa call him the
white wolf which we have heard him
called a few times throughout the falcon
and the winter soldier series
but we never saw the actual process of
bucky getting rid of the winter
soldier we see that in the very first
scene here so this very first scene
takes place
after the events of captain america
civil war and before the events of
avengers infinity war obviously because
bucky ends up getting dusted
spoiler alert if you haven't seen
infinity war but that leads us to the
second
very important part of episode 4 which
is the dora milaje
now at the very end of episode 3 we saw
io she appeared to bucky and she was
pretty mad that bucky and sam let zemo
out of prison
and she explained that she's going to go
after zemo zemo of course
is responsible for killing her king at
the time
king t'chaka t'challa's father the dora
milaje
are an elite group of warriors
responsible for protecting the king of
wakanda
zemo killed their king so they want
revenge he was in prison before so they
weren't really doing anything about it
but now that he's out they want him to
answer to wakanda not the world
but specifically wakanda however of
course
right now bucky and sam are using zemo
they don't have any intentions on
letting him go free after the fact but
they do need him to find the
flagsmashers
bucky explains this to io and io gives
him eight hours
and that eight hours soon runs up as we
find the door milaje and ayo entering
the suite of where bucky zemo and sam
are staying
and of course at the time john walker
just happens to be there with his buddy
lamar now like i said the dora milage
are some of the most elite warriors in
the world so nobody really stands a
chance against them
and we actually see ayo use a move that
we didn't really know was possible she
dissembles bucky's arm she does a quick
little move and then it falls off now
buggy's arm
is made out of vibranium it was given to
him by king t'challa it's wakandan
technology and it does look like ayo was
pretty involved in the process of
getting rid of the winter soldier inside
of bucky
so naturally she kind of knows how to
defuse bucky in a way by taking off his
arm
something that he didn't actually know
was possible meanwhile john walker in
the background is starting to realize
that perhaps he can't be the same
captain america that steve rogers was
the door melange kicked his butt and as
he states very defeatedly
they weren't even super soldiers and
this starts the process of him himself
taking the super soldier serum which
we'll talk about in just a bit now the
dora milaje came for
zemo but during all the commotion and
fighting zemo manages to escape
and this brings us to the third
important part about this episode which
is
zemo zemo and his master plan is zemo
running away from
bucky and sam in this scene no zemo
knows what he did
he knows he killed king t'chaka and he
knows the dor milaje want to kill him
but zemo's plan isn't to run away from
sam and bucky he
also needs them just like they need him
zemo is not a super soldier
he can fire a gun but against the super
soldiers themselves he doesn't really
stand that big of a chance so will he
return to sam and bucky eventually
yes because of his plan his plan is
essentially what he was doing before
and during the events of civil war
trying to get rid of the super soldiers
he even said in the previous episode i
have no intention on letting my work go
unfinished referring to
getting rid of the super soldiers and in
this episode when he comes across carly
he
shoots her and all the serum goes on the
ground he holds the serum in his hand
and then smashes it on the ground and
stomps on the rest of them
this is zemo's true plan he wants to get
rid of super soldiers he does not
believe
that people taking the serum can be good
except
for steve rogers he actually admits that
steve
was a one-of-a-kind person zemo
essentially believes that if you take
the serum you have way too much power
and that power will be
abused so zema will eventually go back
to sam and bucky they'll continue to try
and get rid of the remaining super
soldiers but once that happens
who knows what zemo's going to do at the
end he's now free and i'm assuming he
doesn't plan on that changing i don't
think he's going to willingly go back to
jail so we'll have to wait till the
final episode of the falcon and the
winter soldier to figure that out
but that brings us to number four which
is sharon carter and the power broker
now i had a theory
after the last episode that maybe sharon
carter herself was the power broker or
she's working for the power broker and
after this episode i don't think that
she herself is the power broker
however i do believe she is deeply
connected to him and she did confirm
in this episode that the power broker is
in fact a man
when talking about the power broker she
said he wants
the serum back so my theory that this
could be
thunderbolt ross could come true
thunderbolt ross has been wanting a
super soldier serum
a perfect super soldier serum made for a
very long time
ever since the incredible hulk so he
could very well be the person
trying to get dr nagel who is now dead
to make that super soldier serum
showrunner malcolm spellman did say that
we are going to be getting a surprise
cameo in episode 5.
but he did say it's a very grounded
character so don't expect anything crazy
like reed richards or wolverine showing
up instead i think we're finally going
to see who the power broker is
and whoever it is clearly wants the
super soldier serum for whatever reasons
they have
now is sharon carter working for him i
believe so
she did what she had to do to survive in
madrapor but
would she betray him for a chance to go
back to the united states
absolutely and that is what i think is
actually going to happen at the end
and hopefully after all this is done she
will end up being pardoned and can go
back and see her family the fifth
extremely important thing that we have
to talk about in this episode is
carly the leader of the flag smashers
she was seemingly getting worse
at the end of episode three she was
killing innocent people
although as she states she does not view
them as innocent people
and sam believes that she is actually
good zemo tells him to let go
and that carly's too far gone but sam
thinks he can actually talk her
into coming around and it seems like he
was almost successful until
john walker came in and screwed
everything up yet again however although
john walker screwed things up
carly actually believes that sam is a
good person
and wants what's best for people in the
world which is all
carly really wants and it does seem like
she could perhaps be talked down
she calls sam's sister and she
apparently threatens them but when sam
confronts her about it she says that she
would never hurt them
again showing that she would never hurt
innocent people but carly's plan is to
make
a bunch of other super soldiers so they
can essentially rule the world
take down huge corporations that don't
actually help the world
get their resources and help the world
themselves but sam states that she's
going about this an incredibly wrong way
and he does kind of talk some sense into
her and at the end when lamar dies
you can tell that this really affects
her she feels a lot of sorrow because he
was actually a good
innocent person and this might change
the way carly thinks a little bit
and she's being hunted down by the power
broker so i
sense that there could be a team up
coming pretty soon between carly falcon
and sam
perhaps they all come together to fight
the power broker however
at the end she still is a super soldier
and zemo is trying to get rid of the
super soldiers so her fate right now is
really hard to tell
but we'll find out soon enough but
speaking of lamar this brings us to the
sixth
very important thing that you need to
know which is john walker
lamar hoskins and captain america
now throughout this series we've kind of
seen john walker struggle
being captain america he's got his butt
kicked over and over again
proving that he is definitely not like
steve rogers but the reason he's not
like steve rogers is
he's not a super soldier but fortunately
for jon he actually finds a vial of the
super soldier serum puts it in his
pocket without anybody knowing and he
later on takes it but not before
a big and final pep talk from lamar
jon knows that he has to take the serum
in order to stand a chance against the
super soldiers but he's
worried that he'll kind of lose himself
or become evil
but lamar tells him that he's a good
person and he's done a lot of good
things in life
and all the serum really does is make
good people great and bad people worse
and that's all that jon really needed to
hear some encouraging words from his
best friend
and he takes the serum now we don't
actually see him take it but we do see
the effects of it when he gets into a
fight with the flax smashers all of a
sudden he's able to maintain his own
one of them tries to hit him with a pipe
and he actually blocks it and then
bends it and sam even looks at him and
says what have you done
knowing that he actually took the serum
now of course this episode results in
the death of battlestar and this has
an incredibly huge impact on john walker
for many different reasons but one of
the main ones is
that lamar actually was kind of the
voice of reasoning for john walker he
was the one that kept him grounded and
now that he's gone we've already seen
him go
absolutely crazy now of course that was
in revenge of lamar which i totally
understand
even though he definitely should not
have done it in front of a bunch of
people
but anyways main point being that he's
kind of snapped now
he snapped and now he has the super
soldier serum so who knows what he's
going to do now which brings us to the
seventh final point of
what is going to happen next and that is
sam is going to get the shield
how probably one of two ways either one
john walker is going to realize
everything that he's done and simply
give up the shield to sam
or bucky and sam will actually take the
shield from him they were there when he
bashed that flag smasher's face in and
they're going to confront john walker
after this and this is probably going to
result in an altercation
if john walker doesn't give up that
shield do i think john walker is done
trying to go after the flag smashers
no but we've seen enough footage of sam
with the shield to know that he is going
to be getting it and i think
this is the scene where we're going to
see that happen john walker is going to
sort of take a step away from what just
happened and sam and bucky are going to
go talk to him
this in some way is going to result in
sam getting the shield
in the next episode we'll see a little
reunion with sam bucky and zemo they'll
go after the flag smashers and the power
broker is going to start to get involved
so we'll find out what's going to happen
there in the next
episode of the falcon and the winter
soldier let me know what you think about
this episode in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe for more
marvel content and the giveaway details
are in the description and pin comment
down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram twitter or tick tock
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you